this is the u.s. Coast Guard
intercepting a shipment of cocaine
here's the same crew intercepting
another one and another one this was all
in the summer of 2018 they seized more
than nine thousand kilos of cocaine that
was headed to the US that may sound like
a lot but it's just the tip of the
iceberg in 2017 the Coast Guard
intercepted almost two hundred and
twenty seven thousand kilos of cocaine
here along the eastern Pacific that's
because the u.s. is the largest cocaine
consumer in the world and to get to the
US most of that cocaine has to travel
this way through Central America and
Mexico with that comes violence and
today Guatemala and Honduras are some of
the most violent places in the world
it's a big reason why so many people are
traveling north to seek asylum at the
us-mexico border but the story of
Central America's crisis isn't just
about America's demand for drugs
another big part of it is America's war
on drugs
[Music]
cocaine is produced in South America
along the Andes mountain range that
stretches from Bolivia to Colombia
starting in the mid 70s most of the
world's cocaine came from here
distributed by groups like the Medellin
Cartel led by Pablo Escobar but they
needed to get their product here to the
US where by the late 80s Americans were
spending tens of billions of dollars on
cocaine annually and they did it this
way cartels sent boats and planes loaded
with cocaine through the Caribbean to
South Florida for example Escobar's
cartel primarily flew cocaine from
Medellin to the Bahamas and then over to
Miami Miami is one of the principal
branch offices for what can be called
cocaine Inc it's got to be four or five
times as much cocaine as we've ever seen
before the drug has killed at least 34
people just in South Florida so far this
year so the u.s. cracked down on the
Caribbean root to stop those drugs on
the way to America I propose that we
spend more than a billion and a half
dollars on interdiction they started
catching shipments along the coast line
like this speedboat called a go-fast
boat that was intercepted by the Coast
Guard and they worked with the Colombian
government to destroy coca and fight the
cartels in Colombia
the Caribbean root was dismantled but
the cocaine industry kept going
cartels just needed a new route to the
US and they found it in Mexico Mexican
cartels already had ways to get drugs
over their border and into the u.s. so
Colombian cartels shipped their cocaine
to Mexico but their boats and planes had
to stop somewhere along the way to avoid
detection and to refuel and the ideal
place to stop was Central America
especially Honduras and Guatemala not
only were these countries directly south
of Mexico but they had just been through
decades of civil wars and foreign
interventions their governments were
weak and easily bought off and criminal
organizations had power it was an easy
place for the cartels to turn to back in
Mexico
the new cocaine routes turned lucrative
fast the Mexican cartels got bigger and
more powerful and started controlling
more territory and the government
responded it's a war 10,000 federal
troops and police de Juarez Mexico
cracked down with the help of the US he
will not allow his country to be taken
over by narco traffickers this crackdown
was largely a failure it caused chaos
and violence spiked but it did make it
more difficult to send cocaine directly
to Mexico so cartels started shipping
cocaine to Central America to landing
points along the coasts and would move
it into Mexico overland
Central America wasn't just a stop along
the way anymore
suddenly it found itself at the center
of cocaine trafficking and all the
things that made Central American
countries ideal as refueling stops made
them vulnerable to the violence that
comes with drug routes criminal
organizations already powerful in their
countries started forming alliances with
Mexican cartels in Guatemala this group
aligned with the Zetas while these went
with the rival Sinaloa cartel
violence surged here along the northern
Honduran coast where cocaine shipments
arrived and at the border where the
cocaine is transported north by land
with violence on the rise it was now
Central America's turn to crackdown
throughout the region governments
embraced harsh policies to combat not
just drug traffickers but all organized
crime policy is backed again by the u.s.
to find ways in which we can come up
with more aggressive action plans to
improve security we have a shared
responsibility when it comes to dealing
with drug trafficking newly militarized
police forces arrested thousands prisons
filled up but the violence didn't stop
and that's where we are today Honduras
and Guatemala have violent death rates
on par with active war zones and
thousands of migrants are taking
dangerous routes through Mexico to the
u.s. to escape the instability and
violence for decades the US has tried to
stop drugs from coming in but it's only
really succeeded in changing how those
drugs come in and Central America might
be the place that's feeling those
changes the hardest hey if you've made
it this far in the video you're probably
the kind of curious person that
appreciates learning brilliant is a
problem-solving website that teaches you
to think like a scientist and be a
better problem solver they have courses
on everything from calculus to astronomy
to logic and daily problems in math
science engineering and computer science
to learn more about brilliance go to
brilliant org slash Vox and sign up for
free the first 200 people will get 20%
off their annual premium subscription
brilliant doesn't influence our
editorial at all but it makes videos
like this one possible so go check them
out